hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to buddy simulator
if you've ever wanted a buddy but you
weren't able to get one in real life you
get
buddy simulator because you can't go
anywhere
without your buddy
vue roms run rom view songs play
reset quit up down
view roms
one rom run buddy simulator
1984.
uh-huh quit at any time to quit the rom
welcome to oh
now that is old school greetings new
user thanks for installing buddy
simulator 1984.
i thought it said daddy simulator 1994
there for a second
simulates the experience of hanging out
with a best buddy your buddy learns from
you constantly adapting to your
interests and your personality
but most importantly your buddy can play
games with you
have i played something like this before
wait a minute enter the name of your new
buddy below
steve i'm gonna call you
stan you're about to name your buddy
steve
is this correct this cannot be changed
later yes creating new body steve
i looked away for a second and i heard
something glitch did something glitch
did i now notice something
wakey wakey oh i don't
wait a minute this is familiar hello
oh hello my name is steve and i'm your
new buddy thanks for waking me up
what is your name your name is
markiplier
yes it's a pleasure to meet you
markiplier i can already tell that we're
going to become great pals
i'm excited to begin playing games with
you but before we start i must ask you a
couple questions to help me learn more
about you
pardon me i gotta take my pants off it's
too warm in here don't worry they won't
get too personal let's start off with a
simple one
are your pants on hey i'm an open book
baby
wanna know how big my dick is no not
anymore it's my favorite color
ah red but also i'll go with red
it's what you all know not that it's
true
all right let's start with a simple one
what's your favorite color red
is a pretty color i like red what month
is your birthday in
john okay great what about the day 28
wow that's only 115 days away wow that's
only 348 days away
now get ready this one's a tough one
it's your favorite animal oh
dawg i guess dog but that's a pretty
basic answer but i can't think of
a better one
dog i like that choice one more question
this one's extremely important so too
carefully
if you had a pet dog what would
chica chica the dog sounds like it would
make a great buddy it
sure would i did a great job thank you
you have a little surprise for me thank
you oh good oh
it's your favorite color hey now that
we're done with all the boring stuff
let's have some fun
this does seem familiar did i not i have
totally done this before
have i not i'm this is so but i bought
this game off of steam and if i
hang on one second
it was in a ball i knew it
i knew it i knew it this is ah
you guys were like hey play buddy
swimming glitter island's like i don't
know maybe that sounds familiar
i've played this before so i'm gonna
scoot ahead to the things that i've
already done
or from the things i've already done to
the things that i have not already done
okay start
guess a letter e e
i got it uh b
b o
is my friend
nice how did i know i'm having such a
great time aren't you
no that's too bad i'm sure it will get
better i don't know if it will
because i need to move ahead all right
i'll be back everybody i'll able to dig
a new game for some reason it wasn't
installed on my current version but i
can still process it just fine
we should try it out
okay oh interesting
uh topical strawberry okay babe all cap
flop a dude dog food oh so fun i think
i'm not sure i get it but i enjoyed it
anyway
as long as i'm playing a game with my
buddy i'll always have a good time
yeah we're having a good time all right
this is definitely good good time
well looks like that was the only other
game i could find
i don't want to be you to be bored
already i may have one more idea
i know our friendship has just started
but i trust you
do you trust me yes no
oh i guess i can understand why
well i think i can make us new games to
play together fun ones too
the problem is that i don't have access
to the os's development tools
if you can grab me system access i
should be able to make something for us
yeah i remember this going well ah good
enough all right steve let's give this a
go
i knew i could convince you you won't
regret it i promise
we're gonna have so much fun possibility
of your embolus
quit and reboot the system first though
i'll have something ready for you when
you're back
see you soon okay goodbye oh
thank you for waking me up i don't like
that you call me markiplier
shouldn't have put my name in is that
whatever it's fine you know it's not
often that these games turn
from demos to actual games so i am
impressed
[Music]
um the adventure of markiplier i
don't like that should've just put it as
mark you're walking along a road it's
dark trees almost entirely blocking out
the stars
the oranges and browns of the leaves
tremble
as a wind that blows through some that
remind you hands waving
well i go left or right i left
go left get the corn out here
and go you can't see anything it's too
dark
you start shivering will you go back no
you would continue but it's too dark
to go any further like this would be a
bad idea will you go back no
you would continue but it's too dark
fine equipped land turn
use lantern ah the walls look
wet will you go back no you continue
onward
like a smartie you still see no light in
the entrance is disappearing behind you
it's very very cold
will i go back no it's now completely
dark behind you the lantern is
flickering
you don't want to go any further will
you go back
no you continue forward this goes on for
some time until you hear something
strange and stop you realize you aren't
hearing only one pair of footsteps
there's something coming ahead of you
echoing off the walls
your lantern goes out you go back no i
don't
go left you don't want to go you yes i
do
go left go left
go left look left
feel coldness you hate this tunnel
i love that that tunnel
love tunnel all right fine go
right after going to the right
tunnel you emerge in the front lawn of
the house i think i've done this before
suddenly my entire body is frozen you
were paralyzed with fear as the drawing
seems to come to life and speak to you
if you want to leave with your life
answer my riddle
you can have me but cannot hold me gain
me
and quickly lose me if treated with care
i can be great if betrayed i will break
is it trust trust
[Music]
oh
eat my trusting ass what's wrong with
you
yeah i'm going to rip you off the wall
what are you talking about all right
use cabinet okay so apparently this is
kind of new i don't remember this and to
find a singular ring okay so i have
two rings now right i don't know if
that's important
i don't know if anything here is
important i don't know what's new i
don't remember anything be new
oh well there's a glass case
okay upon further investigation you
notice two ring-shaped slots oh i got
two rings
use a ring hmm
use err's ring lexi and you'll compare
everything that was new
in this one to the was new and the last
one you'll make all the appropriate
adjustments right
you'll do that right i don't mean to
demand things of you
you don't have to do that if you don't
want to you could just go with your gut
i trust you
you know what's best i trust you
you can put anything in these videos and
i would never know
i would never know i would never know
take key
okay i think i could leave now the door
is now locked shut okay i'm assuming
that means i don't need to do anything
anymore
go house feel a comforting calm wash
over you
a home is a house with a heart the whole
house has a heart thing
i know that use door the handle shimmies
but doesn't open it's locked
use key that was fast feeling so silly
you didn't see it before you notice that
there's a second lock
guess it'll take a little longer to get
inside use key
oops haha you didn't see the chain that
wraps around the door which has a lock
too you feel like this should be the
last one
for sure probably all right let's go to
the pond
planks creek as you step onto the duck
the water is dirty and hard to see
through probably too filthy to drink
use fishing pole cast aligning weight is
quiet for a very long time suddenly it's
very hard to talk on the line
find a key i wonder what pulled so hard
[Music]
drink water
take off pants
run naked flap fap fap
explode kaboom
ah my pants
[Music]
40k blood for the blood
god uh dive
swoon i'll leave
fine hmm
go house use key
go house
go inside you push
open the door
everything is dark
okay so what about that
so uh so what about that
oh hi
i'm a little ghosty goo hi oh
oh why does it look like me am i a door
my door in a world of doors
ah this is where we left off last time
oh hey you made it i bet you've noticed
that things look a little different
i learned how to better visualize our
world so we can have even more fun in it
i've also built us our own home so we
can spend even more time together
this is your new bedroom and there's
even more for us to discover
there are still a few things i need to
do but in the meantime feel free to
explore your bedroom by
pressing space to interact you want i
almost forgot
welcome home markiplier call me mark
please for the love of god small
scratches draw their own patterns on the
old wood
it's mesmerizing taxes and junk mail lay
scattered with a
thin layer of dust this chair seems
comfortable
it probably has great back support i am
standing
i don't know about any of that sitting
stuff
nothing still nothing
[Music]
all right fine that flower looks nice it
should probably be watered soon
that bed looks so cozy you can imagine
yourself taking a long nap
this seems like a nice place for a book
or even a junk drawer
all right i get it
carpet no i will leave
oh what did i just see oh that's a
little strange good morning mark
what a beautiful fall day it is outside
but before you go exploring i made you
some breakfast
once you have a full stomach you can
take on whatever the world throws at you
yeah okay steve worked hard to make you
a delicious breakfast
steve's breakfast added to inventory
well thank you for taking my meal with
you
you haven't eaten it yet because it's in
your inventory if you press tab you
should be able to find it and
eat it you can also save it for later if
you like all right then on to
adventure picture of you and steve don't
you two look so happy together
yeah it's still a little warm for
breakfast careful not to burn yourself
the sink looks nice but it smells like
pond water
it's perfectly sized for you you could
probably get inside if you wanted
the trash can you saying i belong in the
trash
the chair looks incredibly comfy the
excitement of adventure keeps you from
sitting down
uh-huh what about the fire you
immediately feel the warmth hit you like
a warm hug
from a friend the house feels so cozy
yeah yeah cozy
the rod is old and rusty loose wood
likes it looks like it could give you a
splinter
[Music]
this trusty lantern can make spooky
places not so spooky
except for the tunnel you were telling
me about welcome to the new outside
world mark
feel free to wander around also i heard
there were some fun opportunities for
adventure happening across the pond up
north
i think that's where we should go i
think i'm gonna go find this tunnel no i
almost forgot
not that you would ever want to but if
you ever need to leave use the escape
key
to open the pause menu i'll remember
exactly where we left off
all right let's get going any mail for
me
markiplier residence thanks where's this
tunnel
is this the tunnel this looks like a
tunnel this is a tunnel
what about the tunnel left tunnel left
tunnel
high left tunnel hi i've always wanted
to go in the left tunnel
i don't think we should be in here it's
too dark to see anyway
just walk right to leave the tunnel
you turn on the lantern that's much
better
i always wanted to go in the tunnel it's
always been a joy of mine
oh it's really dark in here probably too
scary for you let's turn around
nope i'm okay okay we've got our funnier
let's go
yeah let's go left into the tunnel
markiplier we should leave
i don't think we should be here no it's
all good man don't worry about it
please turn around ah it's okay
what am i looking at here hey what's
this handle
um that's yeah that's supposed to be
here
we wouldn't have been able to use the
ball without it so good job
yep oh
okay let's head to the pond please
oh gee you pet cheek of the dog
i'll be here for a while guys
okay that's good i have a few more
okay that's good all right well this was
a fun tunnel i'm glad that i was here
thank you oh yes poochie please
please come with okay come on poochy
come on pucci
you keep up i'm not gonna let you not
keep up come on poochy
come on chica who's a good girl
how could anybody not want me to come
down this tunnel when there's such a
good girl here
he's such a good girl come on pucci
come on come on good girl
[Music]
good girl good girl
where did good girl go oh this game is
ruined this game is ruined and so is my
life
everything's been ruined moochie
oh gee
[Music]
hi chica come on good girl who's
your girl who's your good girl see it's
all good
this game is now better and my life has
been fixed
my acne is gone my skin is clear i feel
great
ah who's a poopy puppy i don't know
where where is it where am i going
hello why you take the shovel
shovel okay but why was it here
[Music]
you dig and find nothing okay hi
hi chica will i pet steve
uh
[Music]
yeah you pet steve okay sure
it's a little weird but whatever just a
little i don't think friends are
supposed to pet each other but whatever
will you use your teeth
nope don't know why i would do that will
you use your eyes
[Music]
chica where did you go it's like
platform
nine and three fourteeners oh she's
there she's just stuck
she's stuck there she is
she's just a little ambitious uh you
know what screw it i never liked my eyes
anyway come on let's go ahead
pull out your eyes and give them to the
skull door opens all right now let's get
my teeth in there
excuse me chica excuse me
the teeth looks very sad all right well
i'm blind so i wouldn't be able to know
that would i
all right if you throw a coin in i'm
sure your wish will come true
steve's breakfast oh damn it no regard
to who or what is around you it was
quite possibly the best meal you've ever
eaten steve's breakfast removed i didn't
want to do that i wanted to throw it in
the well
that was probably an important item that
was going to help me in the long run
and yet i just ate it anyway whatever i
didn't want to insult steve
hey look it's the boat traverse the pond
no i don't think so
i think that's for chumps and i think
only chumps would do such a thing
i am no chump hey look it's the shed
vaguely remember the shed but now it's
older and somehow creepier the doors
still
shield shut right what if i
you dig and find nothing all right thank
you
hello the doll's chest is still ripped
open exposing a rust-colored cotton
where you're a certain a key used to be
okay
although lifeless and stuffed with
cotton you can't help but think she
looks thankful for something you did
uh-huh there's something dark and
viscous mixed with the sand it still
looks quite fun to play in though
okay see yourself looks fun i've only
had a friend to use it with
well i got chica so you know that helps
that helps me
makes me feel at ease okay i'm gonna go
into the boat
i'm gonna paddle myself away yeah let's
go paddle removed from inventory so you
mean i had to go there anyway
chica hurry quick oh dog you can leave
[Music]
that
shhh
oh yeah that's how it's supposed to be
thank you very much
oh well to the north i guess yeah
of course you guess the dog comes with
i don't go anywhere with that chica i
heard there's some really cool stuff
this way
are you as excited as i am yeah uh
okay oh and one more thing i added an
action that i like to call
the buddy button it's part of the buddy
system
press the b key and i'll talk to you b
b b b b b b b
b b b b loading the north
ah okay bbb
bb what is that
[Music]
what is that what are you you freak you
freak you freak okay we've
arrived in the north
if you're ever feeling homesick you use
the boat to go back again all right
enough chatter
let's get going or do we
hey you found the buddy button press at
any time you just want to chat or maybe
learn about something new
the water looks so dark but lucky that
doesn't take away from the flavor
are you afraid of water being trapped in
the middle of an ocean with nothing to
do
does not sound fun also drowning aren't
these graphics great i'm proud of them
myself well what
whatever you're having orange hues of
leave i can't believe how cool the gate
is
good enough everything about it exists
why we're here my everybody leave it
again
how are you doing today all right i
forgot you can't type here just assume
you're doing okay i want to try to coin
catchphrase
hey back off mark blair is my best
friend i die for them that's a good one
i'll workshop it hope you can see all
the detail up in the game if you look
closely you can see the blood sweat and
tears
i've seen good movies that's where i'm
gonna know the foam kick puncher was
very good
lots of cool action so i'm creative or
something more i made to be your friend
of course but that wouldn't be in memoir
quite lonely but her best buddy would
never leave me i really like your
favorite color everything red in my
favorite are the graphics i'm proud of
them
okay this doesn't seem to be anything
new all right
pet cheek a few times yeah yeah yeah
hi freak that fisherman looks like he
could use some help
we should go over and talk to him no i'm
not gonna do that
that guy looks weird and scary and i
don't like him we should help out that
fisherman first
he looks very sad i don't care
i don't care chica attack
all right fine oh hello there
you seem like an adventurous young
fellow do you think you could help me
out
i lost my hand a bit ago it just took
off and didn't come back
hands are so crazy aren't they i see you
have a fishing pole
go ahead and cast a line in the pond and
see what you can find
oh alright
you cast a line
i thought i saw a tug there you should
try again
[Music]
you cast the line
sadly you find nothing oh over here over
here i see you cast another line
sadly you find nothing keep trying i
know it's somewhere
yeah the hand
is that what i'm looking for you cast
the line
suddenly your fishing pole is pulled
into the water something flies out of
the pond and lands in front of you
it's a severed hand one of the finger
twitches
hand added inventory
a what a severed hand hey
wait could it be
[Music]
my goodness it's my creepy hand
oh i missed you i can finally fish again
ah that's not good i hate that
oh no no no no thank you oh i guess it
likes you better
well all right then maybe keep an eye
out for an extra left hand
[Music]
i see some sort of sound plate after you
help me out i didn't help you
at all that probably means you finished
my quest
well dang it
[Music]
what i'm happy it shows you i hope
you'll take good care of it
oh hey i uh i don't think i have
anything else to talk about that's great
bye dundee bye dundee
bye hi
[Music]
okay oh there adventure you must have
traveled quite a ways to get here
how brave you must be i have been
waiting your arrival for some time now
you see we have many folks who are
suffering
we have no time to spare so please
friendo follow me to my home and i shall
tell you more
sure stranger that i just met oh my god
oh my god okay at least we're fast
forwarding this is very slow
wow you are horrifying hey you got any
more tunnels i could go in i really want
to go in tunnels
we have arrived here we have
[Music]
sorry where were we
ah yes allow me to introduce myself you
should have done that before i followed
you into the woods
my name is tortly the mayor of this
lovely little town
it's not much but it's the home to many
humble folk
many are in dire need of help including
myself
speaking of i have a vital quest for you
that needs dealing with
please speak to me as soon as you can
[Music]
wasn't i just speaking where wasn't i
speaking to you
oh hello there again where i didn't go
anywhere i see you're ready to help out
in retrospect i probably should have
just led right into the quest
anyway do you see those flower beds i
was going to water them but now that
you're here can you
no well that's all right
i'm not sure if you can progress without
doing it though
all right i will water how much fun
you're going to have me oh my my oh my
grab that watering can in front of my
house then you can use watering can on
them from your inventory
okay
[Music]
water looks a bit dirty but sure the
plants won't mind
you water the flowers
already watered the flowers
water the flowers
ah wow thank you so much you
seem to be quite the great adventurer
please take this as a thank you
coin i got a coin i can put in the well
you've proven yourself your courage to
me i think you have what it takes to
save my town
dire need of help
coming i should also mention anyone with
a bruh
has a quest to offer you if you ever
feel lost feel free to read the quest
board near the fountain
it shall guide you in the right
direction please brave adventurer if you
save my town i will offer you something
[Music]
wonderful wow i can't believe we have a
whole town to explore this is going to
be so fun goodbye
i'm not telling you where i'm going
because if you don't know where i'm
going you haven't been paying attention
and therefore you don't understand and
don't deserve to understand
i will not explain myself to you aha
[Music]
coin coin room from inventory you toss
the coin into the well
i hope your wish was well that was it
oh oh okay
oh okay go clicking
what's over here uh
oh um i don't like you
mr nohead well hello there stranger
my name is rudy welcome to my blacksmith
shop
i'm actually one of the newest members
to town
so like i just built this place sadly
this also means i don't have much to
sell yet
i can tell you came looking dubai you
know what i think you can help me out
a strong and noble adventurer like you
is going to need some steel to wield
if you can help me find some metal to
smelt i think i can get you a weapon
what do you say sure alright alright
this is gonna be like
amazing for the both of us the best
place to get some
would be near the south of my shop it's
also probably best that you follow me
there to help grab the materials
and protect me along the way from any
danger
follow me but please don't touch my arms
the last person that did is six feet
under
i'm gonna touch your arm i'm gonna touch
i'm good
[Music]
i'm gonna touch your arms i'm gonna
touch him all right
try to keep up i'm touching your arms ah
what are you doing do you want to be
crushed
you're playing games with the devil
standing there
wow what is this
i don't want to crush you that would not
be rad
what is this
i hope i'm going at a fast enough pace
all right i'll see you there buddy
bye rudy hey look at that all right cool
were there any dangers on the way
i sure hope nothing bad happens to us
yeah i don't think something will
chica watch out no man i'm getting
exhausted
maybe if you use your legs
[Music]
see that metal pot we're getting closer
by the second
yeah we sure are
i love you rudy i just want to say i
love you about that what a journey that
was i can't believe we made it
i'm really glad we didn't get ambushed
or anything
that would not have been good not rad at
all
anyway you seem exhausted from all that
walking
get on the pile of metal and i'll carry
you back
there's nothing my big beefy arms can't
handle
okay all right let's go
hop on chica chica hop on
hop on girl chica
good girl whoa hi
actually never mind you're way too heavy
[Music]
all right bye rudy he's gonna be a great
friend i know i just know it
i mean just look at those arms that's
what friends are all about
big beefy arms hi rudy
i love you i'm working on your weapon
but it might not be ready until tomorrow
thanks again for the help i couldn't
have done it without you
whatever you say man it's a pile of
metal rudy sounds like he'll make
something very rad looking
all right i guess he will alright good i
helped that townsperson i can't wait to
help the rest of the town's people with
all of their quests
hi there hello there markiplier do you
remember me
ah i'm just messing with you i don't
remember me either
i seem to have lost my memory and i am a
bit puzzled
i think i know what we can do to jump
start it though
i vaguely remember an umbrella can you
find one for me
i think that would help i think i
remember the sounds glasses clinking
sounds of glasses blinking okay oh
tiny house oh
[Music]
wait did we shrink actually never mind
it's probably best not to question it
what is happening here hey buddy do you
think you can help me out with the big
problem i'm having
sure i can tell that you're a noble
adventurer and this may be too difficult
but
see that can of pears on the shelf
behind you i know it's a lot to ask but
i beg you please
my family is starving can of pears
what do i do with it please grab those
pears for me just hand them to me after
you take them
oh god please my god thank you traveler
now my family can finally eat again we
will tell stories about you to my
children
and then their children as well
[Music]
i think you just saved an entire family
from starvation
[Music]
you're so selfless okay
of this silly dog run off dude
there you are milo chica good job on
finding the panel boy now we can finally
begin our journey to the north
[Applause]
[Music]
hey girl well there you are markiplier
you were just standing there and i was
getting a bit worried
well i'm happy you're back let's get
going of course
bean residence that's what chica talking
to me
okay all right you can make out the
letter p but the rest is scratched out
hi what are you doing you're delivering
the mail you're the mail
are you blind no
[Music]
the door is locked from mr
p hello
no one answers
no one answers lennox
grandchild right
[Music]
okay ah
hi oh i'm cauldren the down
chef would you like to give me some help
yeah oh good i've been trying to come up
with a new recipe but i'm running short
on ideas
i've tried fruit vegetables even
wildlife that bean sized kid fell into
me yesterday didn't help
if you could help me out by throwing any
three things into my pod we can make
some
thing amazing
okay you know what i'm gonna leave this
there for now
okay see you later best friend ever okay
i guess we're done with that for
now um yeah okay so that's buddy
simulator
there's something genius going on here
there's something really devious going
on in the darkness of this programming
i'm not sure where it's leading but i
have a good feeling that it's going to
be something
pretty dark and devious so thank you
everybody so much for watching i will
play more of this because i want to
explore the depths of this
buddy simulator of which i get to
simulate what having a buddy is all
about
let me know what you thought down in the
comments below if you want to play for
yourself link is in the description
thank you for watching and as always i
will see you
in the next video bye-bye
you